in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Sean
and Stephanie are with us hey guys how
are you
welcome welcome where you guys live we
live in central Illinois just above st.
Louis about an hour and a half very cool
and you're here to do a debt-free scream
on a rainy Monday yeah so how much debt
have you paid off
we paid off about 58,000 in 19 months
why did it go miking yeah what kind of
money during that time and we made 110
starting now and now we are about a
hundred thirty good what do you guys do
for a living I'm a school counselor
and I'm an economic development director
ah very cool good for you
so what kind of debt was the $58,000 we
had about 20-some thousand or maybe
yeah and that's student debt and then we
have the rest was consumer debt uh a car
a camper like what didn't we have debt
wise oh so you were kind of normal yeah
you just bought something on debt if you
wanted it and then you looked up and
what happened 19 months ago tell me the
story of your journey um Sean was
fortunate enough to get a job promotion
that made considerably I'm more than we
were used to and I kind of felt like
that was going to take care of a lot of
our issues bill wise and then it didn't
and we were sitting around thinking okay
we are just hopping and from payment -
payment and juggling it and it wasn't
we weren't saving enough we weren't
giving enough we weren't doing enough
Christmas was on credit so we decided
that we needed to make a change and
somebody in our family told us about the
Dave Ramsey plan and the envelope system
and said that it was really working for
them okay so I mentioned it to my mom
and said if you hear of a class that
would be great let me know and so it was
like two weeks later and she said I
found a class and I signed you up don't
give mom an assignment yeah love it and
honestly we just had a baby and we were
like oh my gosh we have to go to this
class how are we gonna do this and she
said she'd babysit oh well that's out
that yeah that's hard for grandmas to do
they babysitting so we went to the class
and we haven't looked back since
I love it so Sean I mean you know
something about economics you're an
economic development director this isn't
numbers aren't new to
you but personal finance if we're taught
formally in academia about finance we're
not taught personal finance no we're not
no or not today so when you went into
this Financial Peace University class I
mean because you've probably got a
similar academic background to me you
know basic finance business classes
those kinds of things
what was your aha moment what were you
when you were going through there you
were kind of smacking yourself in the
forehead going I should have known that
yeah there are a lot of different things
are just gonna stood out and and one of
the one of the things that really hit me
was the fact when you said you know
people just say I can make I can I can
make this payment and they they just
keep putting that on more and more and I
think I can make this pain a little bit
I can I can stomach this but you don't
have to live like that you really don't
and people just just keep financing that
way yeah a little bit at a time you
finance your self up to a mess because
very few people just set out and say hey
let's go deeply in debt that's bright
but it's always a little bit of death by
a thousand cuts in it right yeah very
cool so what do you guys attribute your
success to I mean what what are the keys
to paying off fifty eight thousand
dollars in nineteen months um I really
didn't think Shawn would do it if I
didn't get him to a class and no offense
he's the busiest guy on earth so I
thought we have to go to a class because
once he gets his teeth in it he'll just
run with it yeah and so I'm really glad
that we went because I think if we would
have sat at home I don't think he would
have bought in so we went to the class
he was quiet but I knew that as soon as
he made a decision we were gonna be all
in and that's what happened so I'm
really glad that we made a decision to
go and spend the time even away from our
kids is she right Shawn oh yeah I have
17 page spreadsheet with in probably the
first week in the class we're both geeks
there's not a free spirit on us so we're
both nerdy and we were both like let's
just do this and do it now yeah um and
so I'm really glad that we did because
as soon as we were both on the same page
there were some setbacks but we were
really like okay now how can we do this
faster what can we do we got rid of
cable we sold our camper we you know we
just really tried to get out as fast as
we could because we we wanted to be done
so in the whole process from the time
you get signed up to the time you start
to the time you get
through the class and you're going all
the way through and that whole process
what was the biggest money fight you had
I'll probably her credit cards I'd say
you know just kind of reigned in that in
that was the tough part raining it in
does that mean she had some she was good
about you know I couldn't manage these
credit cards well you know let's just
completely take them off the table you
want to worry about it it was hard
that's a heart that was hard to do I cut
up like nineteen in the class nineteen
yeah yeah it made it rain the man yeah
raining in that's like what yeah okay so
the class was cheering you on then yeah
big-time
everybody else is kind of laughing you
were crying there cheering Shawn's
giggling it's just it's an emotional
breakthrough joy is everywhere I love it
well that's cool that's very cool so
when you finish cutting them up did your
life change I think it did I mean did it
ruin your life no no it didn't but it
slowed us down and we had three kids
anyway so we were ready to like do
nothing anyway cuz it's hard enough but
it helped us do things intentionally not
to just go to Walmart to buy something
in or go to Target to buy something we
only buy something when we need it and
now we've saved money for Christmas so
you save money for birthdays we save
money for vacations and we can do that
all with cash and it doesn't feel like
it hurts anymore because we've done it
we've paid for it before she end up with
a better life yeah because you got the
room and you can do the stuff and
there's no weird sense of out of control
while you're doing it deep down yeah
very cool well congratulations you guys
thank you very very proud of you and
your three kids names and ages are I'm
Sophie's here she's five and I was
holding Rory he's almost six months and
Sloan is two and a half years and won't
be caught dead on camera okay so she's
with a grandpa
okay very fun all right you guys I love
it Sean and Stephanie you've changed
your whole lives and therefore your
family tree $58,000 paid off in nineteen
months making 110 to 130 a year nowadays
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream you ready okay ready three
well done you guys that's how it's done
right there boom